The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Greetings,
and welcome to 5.07
Biochemistry online.
I'm Dr. Bogden Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
I have a good problem
for you today.
This is problem one,
from problem set nine.
It is a problem in
which we're going
to calculate how much energy
we get from metabolizing
a molecule of fat,
more specifically,
a molecule of triacylglycerol.
Here is a structural
representation
of the triacylglycerol.
Recognize the glycerol
molecule in the middle
here, that it's holding
together three fatty acids.
Now notice, I picked a
short-chain fatty acid,
a long-chain fatty acid,
and a fatty acid that
actually has a double bond.
Now when this molecule
gets metabolized,
it's going to be acted upon by
an enzyme called the lipase.
It's going to hydrolyze the
molecule into its constituents.
Obviously the lipase is
going to use water molecules,
and it's going to break it
down into glycerol, shown here.
Glycerol.
Then, this fatty acid that has
two, four, six, C6 fatty acid.
This fatty acid has two, four,
six, eight, 10, 12, 14, 16,
C16 fatty acid.
And this one, it's an
unsaturated fatty acid,
has a double bond, and
if you count the carbons
it should add up to 15 carbons.
So not only it
has a double bond,
but also it's an
odd-numbered fatty acid.
In order to figure out how much
energy we can get from this one
molecule of fat, we will
look at how much energy
we get from each one
of these constituents--
namely, the glycerol and
the three fatty acids--
and calculate what is
the maximum amount of ATP
we can generate
when we metabolize
each one of these molecules
completely to CO2 and water.
In order to keep track
of how much energy we
get from each of
the molecules, let's
make a handy table right here.
So we're going to put glycerol
and the C6 fatty acid,
and the C16 fatty acid,
and C15 fatty acid.
All right.
And each one of these, we're
going to follow the metabolism,
and see how much ATP we're going
to need to put in or generate.
Also, the redox cofactors
in ADH or FADH2.
Also, for fatty
acids, we're going
to be dealing with
beta-oxidation.
And pretty much every
single molecule,
when it's going to
be born completely,
it's going to generate
first acetyl-CoA.
All right.
And here, we're going to tally
up the total amount of ATP
for each one of them.
And then we're going to tally
up for the entire molecule.
So let's start with
the glycerol molecule.
Now, if you have watched
the problem set seven,
you might recognize
the following pathway.
As we just discussed,
triacylglyceride
can be hydrolyzed
to form glycerol.
And the glycerol, then,
is first phosphorylated
by glycerol kinase, and
oxidized by glycerol phosphate
dehydrogenase, to generate
dihydro acetyl phosphate, which
can then enter the
glycolysis, and follow
glycolysis all the way to
pyruvate, and then acetyl-CoA.
From then, acetyl-CoA can
go into the TCA cycle.
So let's tally up
how much energy
we can get from one
molecule of glycerol.
Let's take a look
specifically at the steps
where we are generating ATP,
or generating redox cofactors,
such as NADH or FADH2.
First, we need to put in ATP.
Neglect glycerol kinase.
But we're going to
get back one ATP
in the phosphoglycerate
kinase step,
and one ATP in the
pyruvate kinase step.
So the net ATP formation is one.
Now in the
glycolysis, we're also
going to generate one NADH,
in the pyruvate dehydrogenase
another NADH, and the
glycerol-3-phosphate
dehydrogenase will
generate also an NADH.
Now, keep in mind,
this NADH is going
to be outside the
mitochondria, so we're
going to have to use a
shuttle to bring it in.
But we're considering
that we're using
an efficient shuttle, that gives
us the full amount of energy
for this NADH.
So, once again, the
total, it's going
to be three molecules of NADH.
So, going back to
our table, we said
the glycerol is going to give
us a net one molecule of ATP,
three molecules of NADH.
There's going to be no
FADH2, no beta-oxidation,
and we're going to get one
molecule of acetyl-CoA.
As you've seen by
this point many times,
acetyl-CoA will
enter the TCA cycle,
where it's going to be
completely oxidized to two CO2
molecules, and in the
process is going to generate
the equivalent of 12 ATPs.
Let's take a look at where
those are coming from.
Here is a schematic
of the TCA cycle.
And one acetyl-CoA
molecule comes in,
and it's going to generate one,
two, three molecules of NADH,
one molecule of FADH2,
and one molecule of GTP.
Now, if we keep in mind
that for every FADH2
we generate about two
ATPs, and for every NADH
we generate three ATPs, that's
a total of, 3 times 3 is 9,
plus 2 is 11, plus a GDP
is equivalent to an ATP.
That's about 12 molecules of
ATP per molecule of acetyl-CoA
that enters the TCA cycle.
So now let's tally
up how much energy
we can get from one
molecule of glycerol.
So we know we get
one ATP, three NADHs,
now each NADH is going to give
us three molecules of ATP.
Now FADH2, we know these
give two molecules of ATP.
We don't have any
beta-oxidation--
we're going to be talking
more about fatty acids--
and acetyl-CoA we just talked
about, we get 12 molecules
of ATP per acetyl-CoA.
So, the total here
is 12 plus 9, plus 1,
that's going to be 22 ATPs
from one molecule of glycerol.
Now let's talk about
the fatty acids.
In order to metabolize
them, first we
need to activate
them into thioesters.
These are going to be thioesters
formed with coenzyme A, or CoA.
Here's an overview of
the activation process
by which fatty acids become
fatty acid thioesters.
Of course, this is written
for the C6 fatty acid,
but would occur for
any other fatty acid,
regardless of the chain length.
Now this process is catalyzed
by acetyl-CoA synthetase, that
uses ATP to first generate
this mixed anhydride, with AMP.
This process is
called adenylation.
So this activates
the acid, which
then reacts with
coenzyme A shown here,
HS-CoA, which will generate the
thioester of the fatty acid.
Now, here we are using
one molecule of ATP,
but we're breaking it into
alpha-phosphate to generate
pyrophosphate, which is
then broken down into two
inorganic phosphates.
And the energy in this
reaction, catalyzed
by inorganic
pyrophosphatase, drives
the reaction towards the right.
Now, since we're generating
AMP in the second step,
we need a second molecule of
ATP to convert this AMP back
to ADP.
So, overall, this process
requires two molecules of ATP
to generate one molecule of
the fatty acid thioester.
Once a fatty acid is
activated into a thioester
with coenzyme A, it can
now undergo beta-oxidation.
This is a set of reactions in
which the fatty acid is broken
down into a shorter fatty acid
and one molecule of acetyl-CoA.
The process then can
repeat over and over,
until the entire fatty
acid is broken down
into acetyl-CoA molecules.
So let's take a look at
how beta-oxidation works.
Here is an overview of
beta-oxidation pathway.
We're starting with a fatty
acyl-CoA thioester that
has "n" carbons, and by
the end of the process,
we're going to get a thioester
that has "n" minus 2 carbons,
and the remaining
two carbons are
going to be in the
form of acetyl-CoA.
Now, this beta-oxidation
involves four steps.
In the first step, we're
going to use a dehydrogenase
to oxidize this single
bond between the alpha
and beta carbons, and
make a trans double bond.
So this is the alpha carbon,
this is the beta carbon.
So these fatty acyl-CoA
dehydrogenases,
there are actually
several of them,
and they have
different specificities
for short, medium,
long, and very
long chain fatty acyl-CoAs.
But regardless, there
will be some dehydrogenase
to act on any length
fatty acyl-CoA,
and introduce this
trans double bond.
In the next step, we
add one water molecule
to generate a
beta-hydroxyacyl-CoA, which
is subsequently oxidized to
generate a beta-ketoacyl-CoA.
In this oxidation,
we're going to use NAD,
generating one molecule NADH.
Finally, the thiolase, or
beta-ketoacyl thiolase,
is going to break down this
bond between the alpha and beta
carbons, in a reverse
Claisen reaction,
to generate one
molecule of acetyl-CoA.
And the remainder of the fatty
acid is another thioester.
So one round of
beta-oxidation is
going to generate one
molecule of FADH2,
and one molecule
of NADH, as well
as one molecule of acetyl-CoA.
Now let's update our table
with the information we just
learned.
So, as we just said,
for every fatty acid
we need to expend
two molecules of ATP,
to transform them
into the thioesters.
That's why I put here minus
2 for each one of the three
fatty acids.
We also learned that
in beta-oxidation, we
generate one molecule of FADH2,
and one molecule of NADH.
So, for every beta-oxidation,
we generate the equivalent
of five ATP.
Now we're ready to
calculate how much energy we
can get from each of the three
fatty acids in our problem.
Now, for the C6 fatty acid
that's what's represented here,
we discussed, we're
going to activate it,
we're going to need to
use two ATP molecules
and coenzyme A. We're going
to form the thioester.
And then we're going
to do beta-oxidation
Now, for a fatty acid
that has six carbons,
we're going to do
the beta-oxidation,
and the molecule is
going to cleave there,
and we're going to
do it one more time,
the molecule is going
to be cleaved there.
So we're going to do two
rounds of beta-oxidation.
And each one of
these two carbons
is going to become
an acetyl-CoA.
So we're going to generate
three acetyl-CoAs.
Now, similarly, for
the C16 fatty acid--
two, four, six,
eight, 10, 12, 14, 16.
All right, it's going to first
activate two molecules of ATP
and coenzyme A to form the
thioester, with 16 carbons.
And this will undergo
beta-oxidation.
And we're going to do it one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven times.
OK, so seven rounds
of beta-oxidation
is going to generate eight
molecules of acetyl-CoA.
Now let's go back and put
in all this information
into our table.
So for the C6 fatty acid, we
expended two molecules of ATP
to activate it, and then we did
two rounds of beta-oxidation,
and we generated three
molecules of acetyl-CoA.
For the C16 fatty
acid, again, we
activated then we did seven
rounds beta-oxidation,
and we generated eight
molecules of acetyl-CoA.
So for the C6 fatty acid,
we have a grand total of,
3 times 12 is 36, plus 2
times 5, 10, is 46, minus 2,
is 44 molecules of ATP.
For the C16 fatty
acid, well, 8 times 12
is 96, plus 35, minus 2,
that's 129 molecules of ATP.
Now the C15 fatty acid is
going to be a little bit more
complicated, because on one
hand, it has a double bond,
so we need to figure out
how to deal with that.
On the other hand, it's
an odd chain fatty acid,
and as you imagine, the
beta-oxidation breaks off
two carbons at a time.
So the last time we
do beta-oxidation,
we're going to be left
with three carbons.
That's called
propionyl-CoA, and we'll
have to figure out
what to do with that.
Just as with the
other fatty acids,
the C15 fatty acid
is going to need
to be activated into
a thioester with CoA.
So this is going to cost two
ATP molecules, and, of course,
we need to add the CoA.
And now, this is the thioester
of our C15 fatty acid.
Now, since the double
bond is pretty far away
from the business-end
of the molecule,
we can do a number of
rounds of beta-oxidation.
In fact, we can do
beta-oxidation once, twice.
So two rounds of
beta-oxidation is
going to give us this molecule.
Two rounds beta-oxidation.
In each one of
these rounds we're
going to generate one
molecule of acetyl-CoA,
so two acetyl-CoA.
So we get this fatty
acid taiyo thioester,
which contains a
beta-gamma double bond.
Now, it turns out
there is an enzyme that
can isomerize this double bond
into an alpha-beta double bond.
So this is what is
going to happen next.
The double bond moves from the
beta-gamma to the alpha-beta.
Now, this looks a lot
like an intermediate
in the beta-oxidation.
Once again, this reaction is
catalyzed by am isomerase.
And this alpha-beta
unsaturated thioester
can continue in a manner
similar to beta-oxidation.
So, first it's going to add
water to form a hydroxyl here
at the beta position.
Then that hydroxyl is getting
oxidized to form a keto group.
And the thiolase is going
to generate acetyl-CoA,
and another
thioester shown here.
So, from here, we're going to
generate one molecule of NADH,
and one molecule of acetyl-CoA.
All right, now
this is a thioester
of a completely
saturated fatty acid.
Now of course, it's
still odd chained,
so we have one, six,
seven, eight, nine carbons.
So we can do beta-oxidation
actually three times.
So, three rounds
of beta-oxidation.
And it's going to take us to
three molecules of acetyl-CoA.
And the last portion
of the molecule
is going to be this molecule,
which we call propionyl-CoA,
is a three carbon thioester.
So far we have generated
two, three, and another three
here, six molecule
of acetyl-CoA.
And we've done,
two, another three,
five rounds of beta-oxidation.
And we also generated an
additional NADH molecule.
So now let's update our
table with this information,
and then we're
going to figure out
what happens to propionyl-CoA.
As we just discussed,
the C15 fatty acid
is going to get activated,
so we need to ATPs there.
Then it's going to undergo
five rounds of beta-oxidation.
And we generated a total of
six molecules of acetyl-CoA,
and one additional
molecule of NADH.
Let's now take a look
at propionyl-CoA,
and see how we metabolize
it, and how much energy
we can generate from it.
It turns out the first step is
to expand from a three carbon
molecule to a four
carbon molecule.
This happens by adding one CO2.
Of course, this
process will require
the expense of an ATP molecule.
We generate this
methylmalonyl-CoA,
which is a branched four
carbon chain molecule.
And another enzyme,
racemase, is going
to interconvert
this stereocenter
from the S-configuaration
to the R-configuration.
Finally, this
methylmalonyl-CoA is
going to undergo a
rearrangement of the groups
to generate a linear
molecule, succinyl-CoA.
Now, this is one of the most
fascinating transformations
in the whole
biochemistry, and involves
an enzyme called
methylmalonyl-CoA mutase, which
requires cobalamin, or
the coenzyme derived
from vitamin B12.
This unusual
transformation catalyzed
by the methylmalonyl-CoA
mutase, the enzyme that
requires vitamin
B12 cofactor, it's
fascinating because it
involves a carbon skeletal
rearrangement of the molecule.
And this reaction occurs
via a radical mechanism.
The radical is obtained by
breaking a carbon metal bond.
In this case, it's a
carbon-cobalt bond.
Now succinyl-CoA is
a familiar molecule,
you've encountered
it in the TCA cycle.
However, we cannot use the TCA
cycle directly to completely
metabolize succinyl-CoA, as all
the intermediates in the TCA
cycle are in fact in
catalytic amounts.
So, we're going to use
just part of the TCA cycle,
to generate a molecule,
malate, which then
can be converted into pyruvate.
And pyruvate can then
generate acetyl-CoA
to re-enter the TCA cycle and
be completely metabolized.
Here is the TCA cycle,
to refresh your memory.
And this is
succinyl-CoA that we can
generate from the
methylmalonyl-CoA mutase.
Now, as we said,
succinyl-CoA is going
to be converted to malate.
Malate can then escape
the mitochondria
and continue its transformation
towards pyruvate.
So, in this process,
succinyl-CoA
is going to generate
one molecule of GTP
to form succinate.
And succinate to fumartate
is going to give us
one more molecule of FADH2.
Then malate will escape
the mitochondria.
So to summarize what
happens in the TCA cycle,
succinyl-CoA is going to
give us a molecule of GTP,
and then one more
molecule of FADH2.
And it's going to
make it to malate,
and then malate is going
to be converted to pyruvate
using the malic enzyme.
Now, this is an oxidation
and decarboxylation
that happens in one step.
For the oxidation,
we're going to need
NADP, instead of the usual NAD.
So we're going to generate
one molecule of NADPH.
Now for the purpose
of this problem,
we're going to treat NADPH
as equivalent to NADH.
So malate, via the malic enzyme,
is going to form pyruvate.
And then pyruvate, in the
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
is going to lose one
CO2 and form acetyl-CoA.
In the process we'll also
generate one more NADH,
and now acetyl-CoA can
re-enter the TCA cycle
and be completely
metabolized, generating
in the process about
12 ATP equivalents.
So now let's go back,
and update our table
with all this information
that we found out
about propionyl-CoA.
So as we said, propionyl-CoA
required first the loss
of another ATP to activate it,
to form the methylmalonyl-CoA.
But then methylmalonyl-CoA
converted to succinyl-CoA.
Succinyl-CoA generated
one molecule of GTP,
so we're going to
put plus 1 back here.
Then we're going to get
one molecule of FADH2
the generating
succinate, from going
from succinate to fumarate.
And then, we're
going to generate
two more molecules of NADH,
one at the malate enzyme step,
and one at the pyruvate
dehydrogenase step,
so we have plus 2 here.
And, of course, in the end,
we get one more molecule
of acetyl-CoA as well.
So now we have a total of
seven molecules of acetyl-CoA,
five rounds of beta-oxidation,
one FADH2, three NADHs,
and at a loss of two ATPs.
So this totals up to 118
ATPs for the C15 fatty acid.
Now we can tally the entire
ATP yield of a molecule of fat,
of this triacylglyceride,
and that's
going to be 313
molecules of ATP.
Now that's a lot of energy from
one single molecule of fat.
Now, this problem has
an additional question,
and it asked us to contrast how
much energy we get from a six
carbon fatty acid
and compare that
to how much energy would get
from one molecule of glucose,
which also has six carbons.
Let's take a look
at our table here.
The six carbon fatty acid
generates about 44 molecules
of ATP when completely oxidized.
By contrast, one
molecule of glucose
would generate only about
34 to 36 molecules of ATP.
If you want to follow the same
analysis that we did here--
remember glucose, well, we need
to spend two molecules of ATP
to activate it, but
then we're going
to generate four molecules
of ATP going to pyruvate.
And then there's going to be
two molecules of NADH generated,
one at the GAPDH step, one
at the pyruvate dehydrogenase
step, and finally,
we're going to generate
two molecules of acetyl-CoA.
So the total is going to be, 2
times 12 is 24, plus 4 times 3
is 12, is 36, plus 2, is 38.
So as you guys can
see, the C6 fatty acid
generates actually more ATP
than one molecule of glucose.
And that's probably reasonable,
because the C6 fatty acids
have a lot more C-H bonds.
In other words, the
carbons are more reduced.
In glucose, we have
a lot of hydroxyls,
so the carbons are in a
slightly higher oxidation state.
Therefore, there's less
energy generated total.
Of course, one
molecule of glucose
pales in comparison
with one molecule
of fat, which has
hundreds of ATP generated,
as we thought in part
A of this problem.
Well, that sums up this problem.
I hope it helped you realize why
fats, or triacylglycerides, are
so much more energy dense than
other nutrients, such as sugars
or amino acids.